New Year's shocking sexual attacks in
Germany bounced Emmy pees into renewed
efforts to end sexual harassment and
violence against women in public places
in this week's plenary session in space
de chasse à la fam Dolly's possibly
copia Sammy citizen eco-drive estamo a
play Lizzie tamam Aquino path of course
hot if he LaCava so distant moon little
Olivia no Spencer fam do la la TV an EU
survey says more than 60 million women
have suffered physical or sexual
violence since they were 15 at home on
the streets at work mep s want the
commission to draw up a strategy to
fight gender-based violence and
inequality after the last one expired in
sistemas la necesidad de casado que una
estrategia de igual de centro embrace a
mujeres girls and women's rights at the
unfinished business of the 21st century
mizraim kerr says member states should
be locked into a unified course of
action what we have seen happening in
cologne has actually given a push again
and has shown how important it would be
to put this topic very high on the
agenda and this includes a gender
equality strategy cologne is in the
spotlight again this month for the
annual carnival attracting up to a
million people the police promise
increased protection of women and
surveillance of suspects